many men are perfectly decent and
upstanding human beings I'm definitely
not putting on my tinfoil hat and and
raising my Pitchfork and my steak and
and calling for all of them to be burned
in in the Town Square the way that the
conversation needs to be had and this is
the problem with with some radical
feminist movements I would call myself a
feminist but I wouldn't say that I'm a
new wave or a current feminist and in
the way that it that it seems to have
sort of spiraled now where people say
the future is female and and uh Apple
Man the conversation really needs to be
around how can we deconstruct these
ideas of toxic masculinity and and
misogyny and Society because misogyny is
still a very very big problem especially
in the major institutions of this of
this country and in across the world the
police the government the way that women
are treated in all areas of society
still needs to be improved it's about
having an honest and open conversation
but also not villainizing everybody